now let's go back to Norah Donnell she's
in Washington this morning reporting
from the Jones day law firm she's been
speaking with top business leaders about
the Republican tax reform effort Norah
good morning to you again
hey good morning to you Gail we learned
that Republican lawmakers this morning
appear to be on the verge of unveiling a
tax reform plan now the details are
still under wraps but yesterday we spoke
here in Washington to two of the
country's most high-profile chief
executives Jamie Dimon of JPMorgan Chase
and IBM's Ginni Rometty
we talked about tax reform and how the
government they say can help accelerate
economic growth Jamie what's the single
most important thing Congress can do to
jumpstart the economy the single most
important thing barn done right now is
tax reform but it's important the
American public know it's important
because business vibrancy is what
creates jobs and wages but are we gonna
get tax reform or they're just gonna be
tax cuts well we certainly hope we are
going to give everything we can to get
real reform because modest tax cuts
won't make the difference we need tax
reform lower rates simpler system both
for individuals and for corporations to
have a more competitive system we have
driven and three trillion dollars
overseas now that's being reinvested
overseas because people can do a better
job for the shareholder if it's
reinvested overseas because the
corporate tax rate is too high corporate
tax rate and it's also is a huge
advantage for foreign companies to buy
American companies the big picture for
everyone is us being competitive means
the economy grows in more jobs what
would happen if you cut the corporate
tax rate which is about thirty five
percent now to let's say 20 percent what
would happen what would the effect be
it's going to cause economic growth and
jobs you know as any company you think
about it just all of us when you do your
own budget at home you plan your budget
on your after-tax dollar you decide what
kind of house I can buy what am I going
to do on a vacation you do all that with
your after-tax money same is true of the
business the president seems to be
signaling now that he would rescind his
promise to cut that very top individual
tax rate which is at now thirty nine
point six percent he would leave it at
that amount for the wealthiest Americans
would you support that look
I'm I'm I don't have a real issue about
any of that I'm fine this is we want
them to do what's right for the country
and so we're looking what's broadly good
for the country not what's good for our
own personal pockets that July earnings
call Jamie where you said it's almost an
embarrassment being an American citizen
yeah let me correct that I am very proud
to be an American citizen but we have a
bunch of problems which is why we're
growing slowly and we have these
problems and its infrastructure tax
trade and the reason to do those things
is to drive jobs and wages the
embarrassment was all about that I had
read that it takes ten years I think
this is accurate to get permits to build
one bridge today okay took 17 years to
build the Freedom Tower it took 18
months above the Empire State Building
that isn't you know we were the can-do
nation and get stuff done and we've lost
it I just want to get it back I just was
on the Cuomo bridge with the governor on
the new bridge which is fantastic and
it's taken half a century to build that
bridge so just just think what we could
do then if you remove some of these
quote roadblocks right
what you would only share and that's
really where this is about let me ask
you about Microsoft I know you've been
lobbying and talking to senators about
about daca Microsoft's president said
that that daca is more important than
tax reform what needs to be done on that
issue daca is an important topic I don't
think there's any disagreement the
importance of the dreamers the kids that
had brought here they were brought here
by their parents their productive
employees and our companies I have over
30 in IBM and I think it is a priority
to get that settled how they can legally
be here I totally agree it's a moral
thing you know I don't has a big
economic effect in taxes but it's hard
to take you know 800,000 kids and that's
a they deserve the right to stay and
have an opportunity or when they're
brought in that way so morally we know
thoughts are there he put it very - as
important in almost every company we
know made a very strong statement
supporting daca Jamie you've already got
a busy day job but you've been spending
a lot of time in Washington how many
trips have you made this year I think
this is number 21 or 22 but I'm still
doing my job for my shoulder and why is
it so critical to spend so much time
here you've seen the word shadow
president Jamie Dimon the shadow
president but I would vote for them now
why is it so important me to spend so
much so you'll spend time because this
is so important now there's a like an
one more layer down I would add on to
this in that you know how do you make
change really happen you have to engage
so the right word to me is engagement
it isn't about just you know is writing
a statement and putting in a newspaper
that isn't how you get changed this is
democracy there are people with
different voices and so I think that's
really what our job is to help for the
policies that are really important to
come and help engage to get that to
change and have people you know make
change in this country that's why she
should be President so clearly they get
along well but what's interesting is
that both of them are optimistic that
tax reform could get done by the end of
this year the question is whether
Republicans can get it done and I think
the interesting thing is President Trump
is now reaching out to Democrats on the
very issue hoping that there could be
some bipartisan agreement I think that's
all we saw President Trump talking about
making sure that this isn't a tax cut
for the wealthiest Americans it's
probably good news for the president
since he he's very much once that
legislative big three before the end of
the year it's interesting to hear them
weigh in on daca as well great stuff in
that interview Nora and Nora you're
going to start the presidential rumors
again with Jamie Dimon I think it was
just a little bit of a love fest I don't
think either of them is considering any
political future but you know that yet
that doesn't stop a rumor Jamie or Ginni
Rometty thank you very much Nora we'll
see you at the table again tomorrow